this is a production of Cornell
University
what's the outline for the talk today
we're gonna give a little bit of
background on what's the the
agriculture-related
environmental pollution and the
complexity of estimating the Wrights
fertilizer n rates for a particular
field basically the background of why
the doctor and tool was developed we're
gonna talk about the tool discuss its
calibration validation studies and I
will end with few applications I've had
a friend in new environmental policies
that we now promote promoting and so you
know the Green Revolution in the
beginning of the century really enabled
an increase in crop production and it
came with a price so there's a lot of
environmental concerns related to
nitrogen and nitrogen leaching from in
[Music]
agricultural production first of all a
the production of the fertilizer is very
a energy a costly one percent of all the
energy in the world is now devoted into
producing nitrogen fertilizer and it has
groundwater issues greenhouse gas and
also some health issues related to air
pollution overall there's a lot of
environmental concerns and this is the
Gulf of Mexico I'm pretty sure you you
all heard of the dead zone what it's
called every summer
inputs of nutrients from upstream lead
to hypoxia in the Gulf of Mexico and
actually last year or last summer was
the largest dead zone ever recorded so
in spite of many efforts that has been
done it's really hard to show progress
in this respect and it's not surprising
that the insensitive the production
upstream is overwhelming so this is a
land cover a map that yellow are
cornfields
Green is the soy filled so I mean and
this is USDA data and just the immense
honor intensity of this system is is is
amazing and I want to maybe give a few
words about that how we can or what is
currently being done so this is this is
rainfall for a location in Iowa from Des
Moines Iowa this is the months of the
year so typically a corn is planted at
May harvested about in the fall of
September and thirty percent of all US
corn growers actually applied their
fertilizer in the fall it it's
logistically it's it's much easier for
them they have time the season is over
they have time to go in and and and and
fertilize but it's very inefficient to
fertilize maybe eight months before the
crop actually needs it in the next
season so there's a lot of n losses and
basically inefficiencies about sixty
percent of farmers applied in the spring
as a pre plant in spring and which is
better than a fall treatment but still
relatively a or there is some a
different time difference between when
it the propellant is made in the actual
crop uptick in the in the season and
another 30 percent or so apply in season
so this is the more advanced way of
actually supplying your fertilizer close
to when the crop needs it and it's more
efficient and it adds up to more than
100% because some farmers of like twice
both in a fall and in the spring and
when farmers need to make decisions
about their fertilizer and right there's
a lot of uncertainty involved and the
iana or the optimum end rate is very
hard to predict and there's a risk of if
you over fertilize there's actually
lower risk than under certain icing and
this leads farmers or many farmers to
over apply a fertilizer fertilizer just
to make
sure that they're not and efficient
there's no deficiency of nitrogen and
it's very hard to actually get or
understand what is the right end rate to
a particular field because soil nitrogen
is so dynamic and so valuable so it it
has many losses pathway many a sources
of n inputs there's organic matter which
goes mineralization in the field and a
lot of transformation going on in every
location in a field and changes in time
and in space so it's very hard to
understand how much soil you really have
in your fields of how much nitrogen you
have in your soil so the the fertilizer
industry has been promoting what they
call the for our concept maybe you heard
of it it's basically that farmers should
supply their fertilizing the right
source the right rate the right time in
the right place the four hours of
nutrient management as a concept this is
a good concept it could really advance
farmers into better manage their field
however it is a lot of it's very hard to
implement this concept so what is the
right rate for a specific field what is
the right source is it depending on the
rate is depending on the time and so on
all of these are is basically interact
with each other so farmers have very
difficult times in implementing full for
our approach and we in the last few
months we've been developing this
conceptual model of how an N rate a
dynamic way to estimate nitrogen
fertilizer rates should be so in each
field the farmer have its resources the
soil type soil health the condition of
the field the climate there are factors
which the farmer actually control the
hybrid use of cover crops yes or no what
are the tillage and when you need to
make a decision about your n rate you
need to know I'd be either four or three
hours the source of placement in the
timing and of course the whole field is
subjected to weather the effect of
weather precipitation temperature solar
radiation or these things that drive to
transform a
staff nitrogen in the soil so all these
factors basically continuously interact
in space and in time to to decide or to
affect the soil and crop n in any given
moment in the field and you can use
external inputs like remote sensing like
soil test to help N and and and
basically and validate or correct your
your estimation of what soil and and
crop n in your field and after you have
a good sense of the soil and in Copiah
you need to account for the potential so
what are you what use are you expecting
in your field how what's the potential
of that specific field
what's the economics how much did you
pay for your grains how much do you or
you'll get for your grants how much you
pay for your fertilizer what's the risk
and in the end you can estimate the
right end rate for a specific location
and this is of course a very challenging
and we believe that modeling is a way
forward to do that and and so when you
want to develop a model the way you do
it you basically you need a lot of field
data which they need to calibrate your
model and then validate your model and
if you're happy with the validation you
move on if not you go back and you're
repeatedly collect more data calibrate
and validate and in the end your you
need to have an independent model
evaluation after your your you feel it's
it's validated in us so the enough end
tool uses the precision and a precision
nitrogen management model the PNM with
some other developed here at Cornell by
Jeff and Melkonyan it's a it's a
combination of two different models a
soil chemistry model each N and a crop
growth model model of Sinclair so the
leech n does the hydrology and the
biogeochemistry of the soil the movement
of worded a transformation of carbon in
nitrogen and and that in turn affects
the crop or the growth of a crop which
in this case maize to give a holistic
approach to to modeling the the system
so you need data to validate the model
so we were lucky here that was before my
time of course but Cornell was lucky to
have the with bow Elizabeth is neither
made of bloods farm it's a farm a close
to Lake Champlain in Vermont it's
basically a farm where you have a
difference in soil textures and Cornell
has installed this extensive lysimeter
plots which allow for to test different
soil treatments and collect the drainage
and and the leaching and and and and
then allow a extensive testing of the
model and so the pnm was validated using
this a farm and these are few of our of
the results I would go quickly on that
so this is for nitrate and leaching
basically a good agreement between
simulated and measured nitrate so in
nitrate a or the leached nitrate and
this is where another experiment where
they had a manual application which adds
complexity to the to the model but still
the PNM simulated quite nicely with a
good agreement between a measured data
the model was also validated for other
components like crop and or the yield in
different studies so overall the model
does a good job in predicting the
different components and that was the
background or or the PNM was one of the
main once the the model was validated
and so in the early 2000 early came to
the understanding that it could be used
to predict a soil or the nitrogen
dynamics so that's how I adapt n was
born so what is adapt ended up in is a
decision support tool to help farmer
estimators soil end in complex
production environment and it
effectively addresses multiple
environment sorry multiple environmental
issues of water quality the gaseous lost
is greenhouse gas or ammonia mission
and the energy costs and adapting was
developed as a public-private
partnership with a company called atc
ergonomic technology corporation a
start-up company which has had the
license to to the model and it was
commercialized in 2013 and a few months
ago atc was acquired by jana for those
who don't know jana international is the
world's loudest fertilizer production
company it works in 160 countries and
they a sort of potential in the tool and
they will invest further and and and and
keep on developing the tools for other
crocks and other locations and this is
maybe the time to just to disclose that
yalla supports some of the research of
daft and here at this in Howard's lab ok
so what is the the features of adapt and
I will not go into all of this I'm just
a quickly go over it's a very flexible
tool it allows a has multiple soil
inputs and it goes on a daily time state
daily time step resolution high
resolution of climate data it's a six
hour lag real almost real-time of Crimea
data and 4x4 kilometers resolution in
space a special resolution and sorry
very flexible in terms of management
inputs of the tillage a of the
fertilizer input could be either
inorganic or organic like manure or
cover crops and in many a different
practices which are actually being done
on real fields and very importantly it
allows input from the farmer so the
farmer has measurements of soil and it
can add it to the mother and the mother
correct estimates according to the
observations in the field and
does adapt in recommend and rates or
what's the adapting approach it's a
dynamic must balance must balance
approach but it means that the nitrogen
accommodation is dependent on the
expected yield the grower needs to
supply what is a reasonable yield for
that location and then the model in
accounts for how much is already in the
crop and how much is already in the soil
in this two components are simulated by
the PNM order okay and then it accounts
for the previous crop fair credits for
example soybean and future gains for
mineralization for that soil type for
that location or losses fruit weather
and another profit risk factor that
accounts for the the prices of grain and
filter either it could be run either on
a whole field could be run on a zone it
can be run in a fully gridded VLT a
high-resolution variable rate a
prescription very flexible and and in
accommodating real-life practices the
tool was independently validated now in
many studies I wouldn't just show a few
of them this is a study that we had
published two years ago in agronomy
journal which used trip trial data from
113 trials a in New York and in Iowa and
in each trial we had either a rate
recommended by adapt n using our
adaptive approach or by the grower a
selected rate and these are the results
just to quickly walk you through so this
is the grower rate adapt n rate and this
is the one to one line so if the data is
higher or above this line it's either
grow rate is higher then respective
adapt n rate and what we found that in
83 percent of the ultras adapting
actually allow the reduction in an
application and quite significant 45
kilograms per hectare cross to 35%
action in in fertilizer input just note
that there was few instances few cases
were adopting actually recommended
higher end rates than the grower in the
winter season and so it's not only
reducing it's about adjusting the right
in rate to the specific location and
these are the the yields so practically
there is no difference in yields between
a dynamic approach and the static or
basically the grower approach and this
means that the 34 or 35 percent of
additional nitrogen supplied by grow is
actually in excess you can actually
reduce that without reducing your yield
and in fact the yield is if you look at
the different it's just it's not
significant but it is higher for that
and because there are cases like I said
before we are adopting recommended more
nitrogen that led to much higher yield
and of course if you reduce your n
inputs and you don't reduce your yield
you increase your profit and enough n
leads to increase of $65 per hectare
which is a significant increase and it
just proved that it could be a win-win
situation you can actually M apply less
nitrogen and still make it more
profitable for the farmer what about the
environmental losses so this is
simulated losses this is not measured in
all of this hundreds of trials and so an
average reduction of 36% in leaching
losses and close to 40% in gaseous
losses so there's also a large
environmental benefit in using a tool
like that and so there are many tools
that are not promoted for US corn
production which are static meaning day
for the same season they recommend the
same end rate and regardless of the
seasonal weather and for
New York one such tool is the corn n
calculator which is called the CNC it's
a tool that was originally developed
here at this department maybe 40 years
ago and historically it's the tool
that's been promoted for farmers in the
state of New York so we wanted to
compare our adaptive approach to this
static a tool and we did it using
multiple --android trials what is that
des is trials where you have multiple n
rates where you have your do you collect
the yield and then it allows you to
construct this curve it's called the
response curve and you can actually
calculate the optimum and rate for
specific season for specific field and
this is of course a perfect hindsight
okay so this in the end of the season
you know what in hindsight was the
optimum n right but it allows to then
take a different tools that could have
10 or like the CNC and compare them
using this data and see how do they
perform and a few words about the CNC
it's a static tool basically it's a
factor which multiplies by by dieter
yield and some correction for the soil
and in the efficiency of drainage in a
location and we compare it to that
adaptive tool so both of the tools rely
on yield input okay so this is very
important on the left here what you can
see that this is the achieved yield in
the trials versus the estimated the
years that were estimated by the growers
and we found that growers have a very
good sense of what's the the potential
of their field okay
a remarkable actually quite freed three
bushels per acre difference and if you
use the the actual default yields in the
database of the CNC we found that it
underestimates the yield that were
measuring in the field so in quite
largely in about 60 bushels per acre and
you use these default yields which come
with the CNC database and you use that
to generate and recommendation this is
the outcome so this is the optimum and
rate measured in each fields and this is
the recommendation so this is for the
default yield of the CNC basically we
found it to be under the optimum n rate
because you have a low estimation of the
yield so that drives a low
recommendation and below the Eowyn our
men rate 40 pounds below and if you take
the measured yield or the estimated
deals that's by the farmers and you plug
it into the calculator we found that
it's actually other estimates the yield
to me the the ER now by close to 80
pounds per acre so it's not just about
correcting the yield input and if we
compare adapt and to the EO and now we
found I'm actively a better performance
it's an average six pounds below the
optimum end rates which is quite
remarkable because just remember that
you know these decisions regarding the N
rates are are made in the beginning of
the season you don't know what will
actually be a occur you know as the
season progresses and and and and the
tool was able to you know when the UNL
was was was low the to recommended lower
and rates and when the ER now is higher
that's were committed more and as an
overall a nice correlation between n
rates and the measured optimum so this
we just supports that our adaptive
approach is is performs better than than
a static approach okay so and up then
competed in the Thule nitrogen reduction
challenge I don't know if you heard
about it it's it's a challenge which
initiated by Tulane University and they
basically called for four teams from
around the world to submit their
solution to reduce to reduce the
nitrogen a leaching from agricultural
production systems and seventy-seven
teams they applied their solution from
around the world it's a two it was a two
and a half year process and a committee
of 16 experts they reviewed each tool
and there were finalists that were
invited to apply their tool on real
production environments and real farms
in Louisiana and demonstrate the tool
and a month ago two months ago we were
invited to New Orleans where we were
told at adapt in won the competition so
out of 77 teams that the committee found
our solution to be a optimal and and
that was really encouraging there is a
nice prize associated with that that
would go into further development of the
tool but more than that it's the
recognition that other people also see
the potential of our tools of the
potential of this approach of of a
dynamically estimating n rates and that
was of course very encouraging okay so
in the few minutes that I have I want to
just present how we use it up then in
environmental policies and there are
large companies like Walmart but not
only what a large retail companies that
that want to reduce their their carbon
footprint and Walmart for example came
to the conclusion that fertilizer
accounts for almost 50% of their carbon
footprint and they're looking to ways to
to basically track the sustainability of
their of the production and and and how
they can improve it
and we in in a paper just recently
accepted to bioscience we we think that
index called the end surplus or n
balance is a suitable index for that and
and this it's a very nice paper it's
freely available in in bioscience
website and so what is n surplus it's a
very simple index it's n inputs either
by fertilizer or by my new organic other
organic a - the amount of n which is
removed by the crop okay so the what's
left behind the surplus this is the
index and there are many studies now
that find that n surplus when you
increase n surplus a foot in the first
stage you have no increase in your new
squared losses so basically the
fertilizer you you add translate into
higher yields so there is it's not lost
to the environment but there is a
threshold in n surface where further
increase really drives environmental
losses increase and the idea is that you
can use this so a and surplus index to
track a or to better track the
sustainability of your field and I will
show that here we explore this in the
bioscience paper using synthetic
simulations and we had five states in
five biggest con production states and
when I did in in the Midwest and three
scenarios full tree plant where most of
the corn is a most of most of that
fertilizer is applied in a fall spring
pre plant where most of the filter is
applied in a spring and a split
application where you have a more
distorter in the beginning of the season
but most of the filter is applied in
season okay and we always use the Duff
tend to check if there is there is any N
deficiency is expected and if there was
we added more end so we eliminated any
in deficiencies in all of our scenarios
all of our simulations
this is the result we found it is a nice
relationship between an circus and
musical end losses for our Midwest
location and what we also found that
full application here in the Blue has a
mean value of a hundred seventy-five
kilogram and surface value of 175
kilogram per hectare and if you shift
your application to the spring the green
here you immediately reduce it quite
substantially to 125 kilograms per
hectare and if you reduce it or you
shifted further into the season you can
actually have a mean value of close to
thirty kilograms per hectare so there's
a lot a lot of improvement that can be
done by shifting the timing of your
management into in season and but we
wanted to further explore what else can
growers do to reduce their and surplus
so what I did I used a field data so
this is experiment of that 127 trials
that we had in seven US states in every
trial we had either a rate a recommended
by adapt an a dynamic approach versus a
static approach and what we found is
that in surplus is also of course
related to the yield squared losses it's
much more noisier than our simulation
results but if we add here that the beam
that you can see that it starts to
increase actually at about 75 kilograms
per hectare of an surplice Vario but we
wanted to really get a more quantitative
estimation of this a threshold so we we
did regressions a hockey stick function
or basically there's a seg
which is straight which connected to a
linear increase and the inflection point
where n or n losses begin to increase
with n surplus is optimized so what we
found that we did it two times first to
the adaptive data set it for a static
data set separately and what we found
that about 48 kilograms per hectare
about 50 is a region where n losses
really begin to increase in our
experimental sites so now we've taking
this threshold and we went back to the
data and compared the treatments so here
is the 48 a kilogram of enterprise value
this is another value from the
literature 78 kilograms for a paper by
zhang a two three years ago a it's a
[ __ ] it's a larger so it's a more
relaxed and surplus a upper limit and
this is what we found this is the
cumulative distribution right so our
start of our experimental and data so
when you use a static approach only a
mine about 15 percent of the time you
can actually meet that target of then
the 50 or 48 kilograms per hectare of n
circles and if you use an adaptive
approach that's you have three times
more likely to be within that region
it's close to 50 percent of the time you
are within that a limit and this got us
thinking because you know if using a
tool like a defend which is one of the
more advanced tools out there even using
a tool like it up in only 50% of the
times farmers are able to meet those
those regions of answer Brussels where
Anastas begin to increase so what is
realistic what is a realistic model to
expect for farmers if you now want to
build and and and and and and tell
farmers to improve their their
management you have to give them a
realistic set of values so we extended
the bioscience simulation to include
more soil types we added inhibitors and
similar to the to the bioscience
approach in
relation we always supplied enough n to
eliminate any n deficiencies and this is
what we found this is for a standalone
course low across the soil in a dry
location like Nebraska and so if you use
a full application without inhibitors
you have about 30 percent of the times
we always in the region that or the 48
kilogram a let's say target adding
inhibitors improves the situation you
can bring more cases into that region
for a spring application further
improvement adding inhibitors to our
spring application still another
improvement but the real improvement
goes or happens when you move into the
street application and go in season and
just supply fertilizer closer to one
crop actually it needs it and in fact
just by shifting your management into
incision it's very feasible to to match
those targets if you're in a dry
location so so it can be done but what
happens if you're in a much wetter
location like Indiana and so this is
full application without inhibitors this
is full application with inhibitors are
great improvement yeah but I mean it's
just way off the target and spring
without inhibitors and spring with
inhibitors better than the fall but
still a lot of the times you're not
within a target region and when you do
the
sprits application it's of course the
largest improvement but still 60% of the
times you can't make it or very hard for
farmers to actually maybe we think that
that region a target region so what else
can they do
what's what are the options for greater
efficiency first of all farmers can it
could be a trade-off between the farmers
profit and in the environmental aspects
you can do a modest yield reduction by
not basically pressing the system so
much and I will the next slide I will
present that you can have further
optimization by a multiple an
application throughout the season today
they have high clearance equipment
farmers can actually go to three times
within the season and almost spoon feed
their crop with the nitrogen so a much
more efficient way of supplying your
nutrients and you can have a greater use
of cover crops in our simulations here
we found so the in many cases there were
a lot of residuals so n in the soil in
the end of a simulation and this is here
a highlighted in the red color so the
red is cases where the residual soil end
is greater than 50 kilograms per hectare
and there's quite a lot of it not
surprising rates well the simulated
yield losses are low but this is just
usually soil and in the end of the
season is prone to be lost during the
winter or during the early spring the
next season so if you can apply cover
crops that can actually consume and use
this residual so n so if I want to
again this is the the response curve of
an r8 and yield this is from 16 trials
that we had in Indiana and the black
line is the mean value of all these
experimental sites and Green Line is the
optimum n rate calculated for this curve
and as you approach the the high end
rates that the increasing yield of
course diminishes and it's it's less
efficient so you get less yield her
nitrogen that you apply when you go to
the higher regions and in fact if you
reduce just five bushels from that
optimum and rate which is about two
percent of your yield you reduce 60% of
your n inputs if you reduced ten bushels
which is still only five percent
reduction in yields you reduce almost 30
percent of n inputs okay so what we and
this is this is something we are now
exploring this can be translated into
reduction in n surplus so the five
bushels reduction in yield is actually
30 kilograms per hectare reduction in n
losses and the farmers of course will
need to be compensated for that they're
making less profit but so the
compensation would be about 20 dollars
per hectare if you reduced 10 bushels
it's about fifty or forty five a
kilograms of in surplus reduction and
about sixty dollars compensation and the
idea is that you can now go into those
locations where it's actually very prone
to to losses and and and and and just
maybe help shift the trials back into
the region by nuts stressing the system
so much and compensating the farmers for
further profit loss okay so if you'll
take home messages from this seminar
adopt n allows
action of n apply an application without
reduction of yield and and it just
proved that there could be a win-win
situation where the farmer it increases
its profit and and there's less
environmental pollution we found a
dynamic approach to be much better than
a static approach in estimating n rates
and it leads to to higher profitability
and lower environmental pollution and a
tool like that then could be used to set
standards to of what is achievable any
any efficiency or in surplus values for
different production environments and
then policy makers in news based and us
and and think what are the practices how
wouldn't what practices can we promote
that will help achieve those a standards
or achieve those targets and and perhaps
they could shifted that the production
environment into a more sustainable
production okay thank you
many people collaborated in help of
course along the years of course how old
a Jeff and Peter and many others and of
course a lot of funding helped along the
way and I'll be happy to answer
questions if you have thank you
[Applause]
yeah so we did that and we have adapting
can simulate multiple either night by
rain like a notification inhibitor or a
duel more like a always inhibitor and a
notification so does many its inhibitors
we do simulate the data that have
presented is from Nitro pirates so
that's an extra 15 inhibitor you're in
equation in soil that would be and then
you have a and expected in the future
yeah so for each so for each site we
have in the in the estimation of n rates
okay so when you adapt and recommend a n
rate so it's true that you have that
simulated in the crop in an end by the P
N and there's also a component that
accounts of future mineralization so
that's so that's depending on the
organic matter for the site specific and
it's based on long term simulations for
a similar sort of in a similar region
so what's yes that's an expected sim
contribution from mineralization for
that soil type in that region for the
coming season and how what is here to
answer
[Music]
between like or most the us were were
very good shape we're probably going to
be looking questions yes so so the soul
type the soul inputs are according for
or depending on the location yeah yeah
so you can't really calibrate the model
for everywhere your your client it's
been calibrated quite extensively in the
Midwest and in the Northeast and in
mid-atlantic in North Carolina and so
you know if if we have better data for
that location through a calibration
study we we improved the coefficients if
not correctly for wrong how there's a
default coefficient depending on the so
type in organic matter and and USDA de
it uses a lot of site-specific
information so we have Cyril databases
relating to in a way interesting issue
that we have because of the plane
challenge the technology to our
submission and then we have to prove and
so we even though we had we have a model
available for that and so here you are
in like the Olympics you only get one
shot you know what to do it right so but
we were very very happy with the model
so it's robust enough you know so you
have the weather in your simulation how
can you do like okay so a forecast of
course of course so the components that
use the historical simulation like the
losses this is the component here the
future minimization also temperature you
know and so it's all hard to predict for
to be soil temperature in three months
from now so it's based on long-term
simulation of historical data and I know
that there is a feature that the company
is working on where it will be a
short-term forecast
I'm not months probably
a few days or maybe a week our I don't
know exactly but that will allow to also
account for the meal weather forecast
when and if there's like a rainfall or
some future immediate losses which are
expected so the N rate will be corrected
to account for that and this is a
feature that they're working on now it's
not currently implemented in the model
[Music]
yeah but we do what we do account for
that by those historical simulation and
of course there's uncertainty I mean you
do 20 or 30 years of simulation and you
get an expected season or with
uncertainty you can in you can account
for that uncertainty or correct your
estimation but it's its historical it's
true it's a source of uncertainty in
model prediction any question yes yeah
and so the modern accounts for the
hybrids that act the growler needs to
the long list of hybrids that the farmer
need to or basically supply which one is
being used on that field and then the
parameters are tuned for
I'm
he were building building knowledge
basin every generation what questions
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu